I wanted to apologize first to the lineswoman, to the USTA,...
...to my fans most of all,...
...and to Kim Clijsters who ended up having such a wonderful tournament...
...and winning the championship.
And what an amazing feat that was.
For a major emotional outburst that I had...
...and I think, which I pretty much covered it.
And I just really wanted to apologize sincerely,...
...because I am a very prideful person,...
...and I'm a very emotional person.
I'm a very intense person...
...and I think, it all showed.
And most of all, I am a very sincere person.
I wanted to offer my sincere apologies to anyone that I may have offended...
...and I would like to again thank the fans for all the support that I've gotten.
And I think that's awesome, and I think it's cool that I've gotten so much support.
And I appreciate everything.